do you need to buy a used tractor hey
I'm Mark Hall with Alabama Cooperative
Extension system a lot of people are
just getting started maybe getting
started as an organic farmer or you've
got land that you need to keep bush hog
and you're paying somebody to Bush Hog
and you wonder would it be cheaper to
buy a tractor in a bush hog we're going
to talk with Wayne Green who's a farmer
in Lauderdale County and uh he's bought
and sold equipment over the years and
he's going to tell us about buying a
lowcost tractor we're not talking about
a gently used tractor we're talking
about a tractor uh a low dollar tractor
at a get started tractor just a maybe a
limited use tractor why you tell us
about buying a tractor what do you need
to think about what do you need to look
for and buying a used tractor you know I
have Farmers that has five acres and
some has 10 and some of them has 100
acres what size tractor they need what
horsepower what's the most economical
forum and uh so I try to help them with
that uh this is a uh 30004 tractor which
I'd recommend for somebody had 5 or 10
acres uh maybe you know to do a little
tillage work or maybe uh bushhoging or
stuff like that with it's a it's a real
nice
tractor what I usually look at when I
buy a tractor I usually want to check
the engine oil in it and see if the
engine oil is good and clean in it and
then I I try to check the tires and make
sure the tires are very expensive now
and see if the tires are good on it then
I try to check the uh the steering on it
make sure the steering is tied on it
check your hydraulic lift I tried to see
if it'll raise up and how fast it'll
come up and uh check the PTO which is
the pair takeoff that turns a bush hog
if you're going to do any bush hogging
with it what what is clean oil in a
tractor this is the oil in this tractor
if you notice here in the sun see how
bright this oil is how pretty and bright
it is put it on your finger it's got a
pretty bright color so that tells me the
oil in this engine you know is real
clean yeah and you you can also tell by
oil if you see a lot of flakes in it a
lot of real shiny stuff like glitter
yeah that means you've got an engine
problem yeah if it's real black and dark
the tractor has not been taken care of
you know and you can always hold it out
in the sun you know and and that all
that light will show you what condition
you're oil is in uh would there be
anything else in the oil that you'd look
for water or is is anything like that in
issue usually if it's got water in your
oil it's going to have a creamy milky
type color so I would you know I would
look for that too if it's got a creamy
milky color it's got water in it okay if
you see something green on the ground
it's it's leaking
antifreeze um and that can be very
expensive if you got a radiator problem
uh and you know your engine uh if you
got most time if you say oil dripping
you got a problem most older tractors 20
to 25 years old you going to have some
oil seepage I mean you going to see a
few light spots of oil as long as this
just not dripping at a steady Pace you
know it's not going to hurt anything
and come up here and tell us a little
bit about tires and what you look for on
tires yes the tires on this tractor
they're they're worn down they're
probably about 30% and they've got a few
dry cracks in them and things but on a
small tractor like this it's not a lot
of weight so most of the time this tire
would probably last four or five years
anyway so I wouldn't on the small
tractor tires is probably not as
important as they are on a bigger
tractor with a lot of weight to them
when is it too much play in your
steering well when you you can always
turn your steering wheel and before your
Wheels start moving I mean you look at
your two front wheels and before they
start moving see how much if you turn
your steering wheel like 3 to 4 Ines
before your wheels move you know you got
a lot of wear in your front end so
that's going to have to be fixed it uh
this tractor somebody has added the
power steering to it and I would
recommend if if you're buying a used
tractor uh power steering is real good
on one I mean you can make it without it
but it makes it a lot easier you know to
maneuver around with power
steering four-wheel
drive versus two wheel drive is that is
that an issue it I you know I would
recommend you know for most 5 to 10 acre
Farmers I would recommend just a two
wheel drive unless you got a front end
loader on it then the four-wheel drive
is does a lot better with the front end
loader uh the
Hydraulics with all tractors even a 35
horsepower tractor now would have
hydraulics the majority of tractors do
have hydraulics now um you hardly ever
see a tractor now with hydraul without
hydraulic system on it how how do you
check what would a firsttime buyer how
would they check to see if your
Hydraulics are good would you look for a
leak or the lift or talk to me a little
bit yes I mean you can always let your
tractor set and um set when your
tractors running and see if it's any oil
leaking out from under hydraulic oil and
also your lift when you um pull your
lever up or your lift to go up I mean
the lift should go up pretty fast if it
goes up real slow more than likely you
got
problems this is a lift system on this
Traer
um which you would use on a
bushog uh see how fast this lifp goes up
on this tractor it only takes like 10 to
15 seconds that tells me the Hydraulics
are in real good condition on this
tractor if you pull this lever and it
takes like a minute for it to go up you
got hydraulic problems which can be very
expensive okay uh talk to me about the
PTO yes checking your PTO on the tractor
you need to to when you put your lever
in into PTO you need to make sure the
PTO starts turning immediately if it
don't you probably got a problem or if
the PTO will not shut off when you put
the lever in the opposition you've got a
problem so either one of those you know
tells you you got a problem with your
PTO if it comes on real fast and it
stops good you know you're good this is
a 540 shaft the 540 shaft has six
splines around it like this it'll be six
of them your 1,000 RPM shaft has 21
splines so uh that's the way you can
tell the difference between the 540 and
a th000 RPM shave is the splines on the
shave one has six the other one has
21 if you're biner tractor and you have
a cutter with a 540 shaft
PTO shaft in your bush hog or bush hog
cutter and you buy a tractor with a
th000 RPM shaft that cutter will not
work on this tractor you will uh you
will either have to buy another cutter
or buy another tractor and um and vice
versa so you need to when you're buying
a tractor you need to buy something you
know that matches your cutter or buy a
cutter that matches your
tractor a what size bush hog would that
pull I recommend a 5 foot for this this
particular it's about a 35 or 6
horsepower tractor a 5ft bushog or
Cutter does real good on this tractor at
what point Acres wise would most people
need to step up and get a bigger tractor
a bigger bush hog well I think if you
get up into maybe 20 or 25 or 30 Acres
you know I would look at going like a 50
horse P tractor and may be getting a six
foot cutter and um and if you got you
know 30 or 40 acres I would probably try
to go to a 50 or 60 horsepower tractor
and get a seven or eight foot cutter
so it's just according to how much time
you want to spend out there using a
cutter now this would be like if
somebody had 100 acres they needed to
keep bush hog yes this would be a pretty
good tractor it
would what what would you look for on a
bigger tractor that you wouldn't what
what what would be the issues specific
to a higher horsepower tractor basically
the same thing applies to a big tractor
that does a small tractor you look under
it for oil leaks and
uh course this tractor uh it has a on it
and I would always get in there and make
sure the air conditioner works properly
on it this tractor here um it comes with
a with two PTO Shades in it so you can
use uh
two
different uh implements on it this is a
th000 RPM shave which is a 21 spline
this is a 540 shaft with a six spline
which gives you an option over the other
tractor you can
use
uh either one on it so you don't have to
worry about that this tractor has got
hydraulic dual hydraulic
vials uh like you can put a front end
loader on this tractor and you already
got your vial set up on it uh like
pulling a big hay roller most people's
got a 15t backwing cutter that they use
with this type tractor uh it's a real
good bush hog tractor it's it keeps you
clean uh inside uh you don't have to
worry about eating dust all day long and
it's also
cool in today's market you can spend
from a range of maybe $3500 to $110,000
on a on a good Ed tractor it's really
according them uh if you want a a
tractor like this 3000 or you want a cow
tractor with air on it you know uh you
can it's a variety of tractors out there
in this range and I tell people all time
you buy a good used tractor 10 years
from now it'll make you money because
they go up every year because the new
ones go up every year so they won't lose
any money you can always turn around and
resell it if you'll just take care of it
Wayne thank you so much for that good
advice and hopefully that'll help you in
deciding whether you want to buy a used
tractor or how to buy a good used
tractor